madame ces messieurs vous rassurer votre
transfert qui sont ils ces types sur la
pauvre tués
soldats on se connaît on ne traîne pas
j'ai été mis aux arrêts sans raison
c'est votre droit les cuisines
ce soldat est quasiment commandement on
a autre chose à faire de plus urgent
j'avais clairement admis que vous tenir
à l'écart a donné à moi oui je me savais
capable de venir me faites pas regretter
à les embarque le moins tu le mets en
cellule deux choses vont arriver dans
les 90 secondes qui viennent on parle
d'abord le téléphone qui est là va se
mettre à sonner
ensuite vous aurez ses menottes aux
poignets en partant en prison alors ça
c'est une prédiction qui me laisse sans
voix
messieurs reacher ça ne s'arrêtera pas
de signer
chérif rayman ou actuels celui que vous
n'attendiez pas
riga
mua
mais tu l'aidés à 13
hawass
dominateurs
je n'affirme allemand il s'essouffle
je sais qu'une bombe
et puis en bois vêtues les théâtres den
d'achat
comment ça va j'aime pas comme suit
deux choses vont arriver d'abord le
téléphone qui est là va se mettre à
sonner
ensuite vous aurez ses menottes aux
poignets ça ne s'arrêtera pas de sonner
vous êtes qui nom de dieu celui que vous
n'attendiez pas
jack reacher toutes ses décorations vous
êtes une légende raconte quoi d'autre
j'ai besoin de votre aide quelqu'un tue
des soldats des hommes qui étaient sous
votre commandement
là c'est l'heure de la chasse je sais
pas ce qui vous motive
je vous jure que je qu'on voit la
réponse personne ne trouvera rien et si
j'étais un seul bras pour te massacrer
avec
les tireurs est trop près comment ça va
j'aime pas qu'on me suivent
qu'un homme mort à nous en tout cas ça
c'est sûr c'est de la peur que j'entends
dans tafourah jack
c'est l'excitation que tu entends dans
ma voix
il s'en va très bien je vous conseille
c'est là